nailed it  this guy is always trying to spoil a bad  thing  ah you guys are here too took the long  way huh is everything a joke to you why  must you constantly interfere with my  destiny because my destiny is to protect  my friends and family i think i just  threw up in my mouth  and if you want that emerald you're  gonna have to go  through  me  [Music]  [Music]  sonic has heart but will he lose the  quill to live  i don't want to fight you but you're not  giving me much  [Music]  too  choice  let's do this  [Music]  let me think about it  okay i thought about it  hi there beautiful  you're the real deal aren't  say goodbye  hedgehog  [Music]  knuckle stop robotnik's stealing the  emerald what kind of fool do you take  before just look  wait  that wasn't the deal  you poor naive creature  it's not your fault  a more advanced intellect would have  seen this move coming a mile away  or 1.6 kilometers  but i trusted you  you're my friend  [Laughter]  i'm sorry  that just hit me funny